wishing you more excited to see nope or
Black Adam
uh nope just because
it's an original idea
I love Dwayne Johnson so like I'm super
pumped about it
but nope original concept will win all
the time for me
again it ties back to
go into an independent movie theater at
such a late age and seeing movies like
Lost and Delirious and Ghost World
Original Stories just have have a
special place in my heart and as much as
I love the spectacle
if you kind of put them side by side and
say do you want to watch something
that's original or do you want to see
something that's connected to a known
franchise
nine times out of ten I'm gonna pick the
original concept
and with Jordan Peele
I mean how can you not love him as a
filmmaker he's he's he's bold he's
ambitious
and get out I I remember seeing get out
at Sundance they did a midnight
screening it was a surprise screening
and I
watched that with a small crowd they had
at the library the library is one of the
smaller venues at Sundance it only holds
about like three to four hundred people
and at two o'clock in the morning
because it's a midnight screening two
o'clock in the morning to hear that
audience just erupt with Applause and
connect and see the reactions that night
and the next morning
and then like again going back to our
earlier conversation about being able to
experience things being the first to
experience things you feel like you saw
something special right and and seeing
Jordan peel his directorial debut seeing
him do something that you had no
expectations that he had in him like who
expected the guy who was on key and peel
to make a horror movie that had so much
depth and like made so many white people
uncomfortable right I mean like it was
it was so it was so funny reading
a lot of my white colleagues reviews of
that movie like everyone was like he
really understood like it was like he
really made me feel uncomfortable and
like everyone trying to under act like
they understood Black Culture at that
point it was it was so hilarious and
then you know Jordan Peele took the
second movie
um oh my God what was the second movie
us to uh South by Southwest
and I and I remember seeing that in the
first two acts of that movie worked
really well and I was really
disappointed with the last act I I
didn't think that movie really was on
the same level as get out
but this looks like it's in a totally
different direction
I have no idea what this is it like
looks like it's a Sci-Fi comedy
and every trailer like
it has elements to it where I'm kind of
like this is either going to be like a
complete train wreck or this is going to
be like one of the best movies of the
year and I I really can't decide because
there's just things in the trailer that
you're watching this and you're like
what's happening there's cows up here
flying
okay like is this twister and then
you're like sitting there and then you
have like kind of like the social
commentary down the on the ground there
and I'm like this looks brilliant so it
Universal definitely knows what they're
doing with him and I'm so glad that they
signed on to to the the Jordan peel
roller coaster ride because I don't know
if audiences are quite
ex know what they're expecting with this
one I don't think people I don't think
any of us know so I'm very curious to
see it so of nope or Black Adam which do
you think will be the bigger hit for
2022
just from the little that you've seen
it's hard to say because you have
short and peel has such a name behind
him because those two movies were such
massive hits
that that I almost want to say that
that's going to be bigger
but there's the uncertainty there right
the thing about comic book movies
is that you already have a built-in
audience
that are going to see it and Dwayne
Johnson is arguably
the biggest movie star in the world
and like he sells movies he's one of the
he's like Tom Cruise right he sells
movies people know who Dwayne Johnson is
they go to movies because
Dwayne Johnson's in it just like people
go to Tom Cruise movies because Tom
Cruise is in it
Top Gun was a success not because it was
a Top Gun movie but because it was a Tom
Cruise movie
so I mean it's a good movie regardless
but I'm just saying like that's the
reason why butts went in seats because
of Tom Cruise so it's really hard
because I do feel
it depends on the reaction of nope
from critics and audiences to dictate
whether that's going to be the big movie
or Black Adam so right now
I'm gonna say Black Adam just because
it's the safer because it has a two for
two it has the Super the superhero
element
and it has Dwayne Johnson where I feel
like Jordan peel has the name but it
also has that original idea that can go
either way
what are your five most anticipated
movies for 2022
we're halfway through
[Music]
we are halfway through
um
well it's not Avatar
there is
a Christmas musical comedy coming out
that everyone's watching this is like
what
with Ryan Reynolds and Will Ferrell
coming out
that I think is going to be a ton of fun
I I I have nothing to basis off of no
trailer just that it's a musical comedy
set around Christmas and I have a very
big soft spot for Ryan Reynolds so I'm
definitely very very excited about that
I'm going to say
don't worry darling Olivia Wilde's
newest movie
she she blew me away with book smart
I've always been a fan of her as an
actress I I know people are kind of
lukewarm I lukewarm on her as an actress
I've always been a fan especially when
again going back to the Indie movies
when she started doing like a lot of
Indie rolls I felt like she was just
superb in them
so I'm very curious this looks like such
a big scale film like book smart felt
like a small Indie comedy like it was
like a coming of an age
Indie comedy but this feels like it's a
massive scale and I mean the cast with
you know Florence Pew and and Chris Pine
it feels like it's big so I'm really
looking forward to that one
I'm trying to think what else oh Shazam
the the second Shazam
David David F Sandberg such a big fan of
him uh going back to lights out I love
the first shazam movie talk about it
talk about just a fun fun movie a reason
people go to the movies just to have a
good time get a little bit of a
spectacle get a little bit of a comedy
Zachary Levi in that just just just
perfect again perfect casting we're
talking about a superhero casting
earlier
somebody who really loves superheroes
and wanted to be one and then he got to
cast as one Perfection there were
casting so that's three
um
I'm really excited about Amsterdam I I
know that
people are a little bit hesitant on that
because of the director
but I think that's a one of those
Ensemble pieces that is going to have a
lot of great performances in it and is
going to have a really good story
and then I guess I I mean how could I
not say the Martin Scorsese movie right
the killers of the flower moon like it's
Scorsese and Leonardo DiCaprio that has
worked in the past so I'm pretty sure
it's going to work again and I'm gonna
I'm gonna sneak another one in I have to
say Babylon I can't believe I forgot
about Babylon Damien chazelle's latest
uh with Margot Robbie cannot wait I saw
saw a small teaser Ford at uh cinemacon
totally up my alley totally excited for
it how would you rate the movies of 2022
to previous years
oh that's
truthfully
um
I don't know if the industry has fully
recovered since 2020.
um there's definitely been some bright
spots
this year and there there has been some
real signs of of Hope at the at the
movie theater
but
Blockbusters this year so far
outside of top gun Maverick
I'm not really feeling them I'm really
not it's I as much as I like Batman
I felt like it was 30 minutes too long
again the ground in reality there's like
two movies there like there's literally
like one and a half movies there's
literally like a cutting cutting point
in Batman where it's kind of like okay
this movie could have ended here and the
sequel could have started here but it
keeps going and then you kind of get
like half of the movie
Doctor Strange disappointment
Jurassic world Dominion
oh talk I
broke my heart I mean I
Jurassic Park is one of the greatest
Blockbusters of all time
I have that on record it's one of the
best movies it's like seeing dinosaurs
come to life for the first time
but the characters every character
you're connected with
the the kids weren't annoying you
actually like you got into the kids you
were like you you felt the sense of
wonder that they felt watching them you
felt the fear the panic
it was like the ultimate like
Blockbuster you just you couldn't
look away from that movie and it's
amazing how 25 years later you can still
watch that movie and it holds up and and
Steven Spielberg really one of his
crowning achievements as a filmmaker
and
Jurassic Park Dominion uh 100 one of the
most disappointing if not the most
disappointing movie I've seen in 2022 so
far
they had all these great trailers
leading up to
this movie which like threw in the
Legacy characters again all these
characters back from the original movie
you're like oh my God this has this
great story to build upon about we're
gonna we're gonna finally see dinosaurs
and humans living together that's what
we've been promised
and it just goes back and does the same
thing over and over again
and the characters have not a single
brain cell in their freaking heads I I
it's just a dialogue terrible editing
uh just what a what a disaster what a
disaster and then you know Thor you know
again it's fun enough
but
compared to what we've seen before like
it's it's no black panther it's no
Guardians
it doesn't have that I mean top gun
Maverick right now is is that is the
movie that is saving the summer
and the the the the again going back to
Indies
is Indie movies better this year 100
with Marcel the Shell coming out and the
other great movie everything everywhere
all at once those are some great movies
and that's why you're seeing more and
more audiences kind of seeing those
movies because they're good